now this is i really like this question
the reason why is because
i mean it seems like it they're handing
it to you
but then you run into problems okay now
what i'm going to do first is i'm going
to try and approach it the way i think a
lot of you have approached it i'm not
going to finish it off okay i'm just
going to get to sufficient enough a
point to um show that there are
problems with the way that you've um
you've solved it they're not
insurmountable problems but a lot of you
have just seen the problem and quietly
ignored them and kept on going as if
they weren't there okay so here's the
way a lot of you are doing it okay
you see this obviously you need to work
out du on dx right you get your 2x
okay
but then you realize there is a problem
okay when you're going to substitute
these pieces into here right no problem
getting rid of this x squared that's
okay because x squared is just u plus 1.
i should write x squared equals u plus
one okay
huh but then you're like what do i do
with this x
i don't have an x here okay now some of
you have resorted to this you've sort of
said um i have a dx okay so you sort of
do this
uh on 2x
i think you've done something equivalent
to that okay now
sorry wait is that a where's my x that's
that's the x okay now
this will sort of land you the right
problem but it sort of does a bit of a
no-no in that the whole point of using a
substitution is to get rid of all of one
thing and replace it all with another
thing okay and you've seen where that
mixes up when you have problems
particularly when you have boundaries
right it's a big no-no to change some of
it and not change all of it and if you
can't change all of it you can't
probably properly use the substitution
okay
now others of you have also tried to say
well okay
fine i don't want to put an x in at this
point right i'll get x in terms of u so
you've gone over here and you said oh
actually you've gone
you've gone over here and you said i
don't want x squared i just want one x
okay so you said this
okay now we've been in inverse trig long
enough that you know you're lying to
yourself just a little bit right because
you're like well there's a plus minus
there
but i don't want there to be a plus
minus so i'll just
i'll just pretend you know he's kind of
like um at family gatherings it's like
that uncle who no one really talks to
you know we just ignore that just leave
him in the corner and don't disturb him
and he won't cause any trouble
but
you can't do that can you you must
resolve this plus or minus
somehow okay so i've identified two
problems with this way of doing it okay
number one you're mixing up variables
bad idea
number two you're ignoring part of your
solution okay
so the question is how else can i do
this how else can i do it well here's
what i would suggest
the reason why this is a problem is
really here this is the crucial point
okay it's the d on dx it's giving us
issues okay now most of you have ignored
the fact that i can rather than mucking
around with this stuff
i can work with my integral before i do
my substitution for instance
i can say if i want a 2x
i can put a 2x there if i do it to the
top just got to make sure i do it to the
bottom right
have i broken any laws
i haven't mixed any variables i haven't
screwed it over any plus minus stuff
right so far so good and i've got the 2x
that i want to okay obviously that
changes this down here doesn't it so you
get 2x on
what's this going to be becomes an x
squared under there doesn't it so that
will be 2x squared minus
x to the 4. now you're like that's
that's created a new problem now i've
got next to the 4. but that's not nearly
as much as a problem as an x is because
x to the 4 has no problems with sine
right here's going to be u squared plus
2u plus 1. plus minuses okay going up in
degree is much safer than going down
okay
so now i'm in a position to do my
substitution i know what 2x is i know
what x squared is i know what x to the 4
is let's do it
this 2x dx just becomes
one
do you okay
there you go
what's going to be inside here it's
going to be the square root of i
probably haven't given myself enough
space have i two of these
minus one of these uh
sorry
u squared minus 2u minus 1.
can you see what's going on let me put
the d u in the right spot
okay
my two u's they cancel
and that plus two minus one becomes a
one
so i'm left with
one on square root of one minus u
squared
and you can see where to go from there
okay so you end up with i'm going to
skip one line and just go straight to
substituting out
the u and get the x back in there okay
so
i'm not finished yet though this is
what's great about this question it
raises some interesting questions um
this was the this was the hard way to do
it there is a sneakier way and a much
faster way okay
this was hard because of all of this
algebra business that we had to account
for okay
but think about how much you are handed
about the question
immediately when they say this
the whole point of using a substitution
is that it's going to appear somewhere
in your final answer as an inside
function yes
otherwise they wouldn't give it to you
now therefore you know this in advance
is going to appear somehow right
then you have a look at this what form
is it likely going to end up in is it
going to be a tan inverse form
no you can already discount that because
it's a square root right so you know
it's probably going to be sine inverse
of probably that so you make an educated
guess okay now the reason why that's
going to be easier for you is because
differentiating
is 10 times easier than integrating when
you've got all this mess to work out
right so you do this you can do this
and surprise surprise you get this
okay so if you have shown that i mean
obviously there's a couple more lines in
here right but you show this is the
derivative if you've shown the duty if
you just integrate both sides and there
you are okay so you see it's an educated
guess based on what they've given you
and the educated guess
works
all right one last thing okay
one more one more here we go
some of you have noticed
at least two of you
that look at this integral look at it
do we really need substitution to do
this integral
we don't we looked at this is almost on
the standard integral sheet right
let's just get that that two out of the
way right slap it out the front
you've got two there but this two right
i want something squared here well
that's root two squared
squared
okay so this is a squared minus x
squared sorry there's dx okay so what
does the standard form tell you
i've got my two out the front
sign inverse
x on
a
plus a constant
that's pretty different isn't it it's
quite dramatically different and my
question to you is
number one have we done anything wrong
okay number two if we haven't
what does that mean